[Música]
el parlamento francés tramita una ley
que busca limitar el acceso a redes
sociales para los menores de quince años
al tiempo que ya fue anunciado que la
llegada de nuevos teléfonos al país
vendrá también con la implementación de
control parental en los aparatos este
debate se da en medio de la polémica por
las denuncias contra las gigantes
tecnológicas por espionaje y apropiación
de los datos de los usuarios son los
niños los más vulnerables vamos al
análisis con Angélica casayas Ella es
periodista colombiana especializada en
tecnología y creadora de contenido
actualmente líderes digitales de rtvc
Play del sistema de medios públicos
colombianos Gracias por estar con
nosotros bienvenida
Hola Ángela Muchas gracias por invitarme
comienzo preguntándole Desde qué edad
desde según su opinión deberían estar
los niños o los adolescentes expuestos a
las redes sociales
máximo o mínimo mejor a los 14 años es
preferible que niños menores de esas
edades no tengan contacto alguno con las
redes sociales todavía Ya que pues por
supuesto están expuestos a muchísimos
contenidos inapropiados que por más de
que a veces se disfracen como contenidos
infantiles Pues no son propiamente
contenidos que deberían estar viendo los
niños sí deberían tener acceso tal vez a
tecnología de pronto a mirar contenidos
hechos para y por los niños
contenidos sobre todo de series
contenidos educativos pero en redes
sociales es mejor esperar bueno además
digamos de la salud de los niños y de
esta alta exposición sobre la que espero
que hablemos más adelante
está este peligro de entregar nuestra
intimidad a las redes sociales eso ya es
un problema para los adultos Pero cómo
esto se graba más para los más pequeños
Bueno pues porque obviamente están
expuestos a contenido delicados ustedes
saben que en redes sociales incluso los
adultos hemos visto Pues todo tipo de
contenido que si lo ve un niño por
supuesto pues no está hecho para ellos
contenido de tipo explícito contenido de
violencia contenido de maltrato
denuncias que por supuesto las redes
sociales han servido para denunciar y
mostrarle a los medios y a la opinión
pública casos que no deberían ocurrir y
los niños Pues están expuestos a ese
tipo de contenido y como tú decías
entregarle los datos a las redes
sociales ya supone en sí un riesgo de
hecho hay padres que desde muy pequeños
o desde antes de nacer Incluso hacen
cuentas de Instagram o de tiktok o en
otras redes sociales para que ese niño
pues tenga como que su vida activa en
redes sociales eso también es un
problema no deberían los padres tomar
ese tipo de decisiones por los hijos
antes de consultarle a los hijos hemos
visto casos incluso de personajes de la
vida pública el caso de príncipes de
Inglaterra que por fotografías expuestas
hace muchísimos años hoy se convierten
en escandalos así que sin consentimiento
de los niños es importante también que
los niños den consentimiento es mejor no
exponerlos a las redes y también es una
irresponsabilidad de los medios publicar
sus imágenes sin el permiso de sus
padres dicho esto ahora porque la
urgencia Entonces se explicaría en
Francia delimitar la edad de exposición
con este proyecto de ley que lo
limitaría a los 15 años el control
parental es realista para evitar esa
sobreexposición
si es realista y digamos que permite
Pues sopesar un poco esta realidad de
que ya tenemos niños menores de quince
años incluso menores de 12 años o
menores de 10 años que están utilizando
las redes sociales entonces hay que
aplicar pues control y que los padres
puedan tener un poco más el control de
sus redes sociales como las aplicaciones
están haciendo por ejemplo controles de
tiempo
tienen como una aplicación que está
compartida con la familia entonces lo
que se hace Es que solamente los papás
puedan tener acceso a un límite de
tiempo y luego si el niño o la niña
quiere seguir pasando más tiempo en esa
red social Pues debe contar con un
código que solamente le llega a los
padres para poder acceder a más
contenido Entonces definitivamente pues
las reglas Yo sí pienso que deben ser un
poco más estrictas y sobre todo pues
para que los padres se den cuenta del
riesgo que supone que sus hijos estén en
redes y otra cosa es que en a medida que
las redes sociales en este caso pienso
en una red como tiktok se vuelve una red
más famosa más masiva pues van a llegar
más personas a esta red social a crear
Pues todo tipo de contenidos que tal vez
para los niños no sean seguros Entonces
es mejor tener unas leyes mucho más
estrictas Sí bueno es que esta noticia
de la legislación en Francia para
limitar el acceso a redes sociales llegó
apenas unos días después de denuncias de
múltiples países contra tiktok por robar
los datos de los usuarios o por incluso
acusar a China de intentar enviar
mensajes a los usuarios para favorecer
la imagen del gigante asiático Cómo
podemos plantear una relación sana con
el entorno digital sin tener que
privarnos de las redes sociales o cómo
deberíamos plantearla con los niños
pues primero que todo y esto sobre todo
para los adultos leer los términos y
condiciones cuando nos vamos a inscribir
o vamos a llegar a una nueva plataforma
esto es muy importante normalmente
siempre nos lo saltamos pero ahí hay una
letra menuda como decimos aquí en
Colombia y es importante leerla para
saber qué tanto de nuestra privacidad Le
estamos entregando a las redes sociales
porque finalmente el negocio de las
redes sociales todos decimos bueno Esto
es gratis entre comillas yo aquí puedo
postear yo incluso puedo volverme famoso
ser influenciador Pero cuál es la
ganancia entonces de las redes sociales
pues venderle mis datos a un sinfín de
empresas para que ellos a su vez me
vendan publicidad a mí entonces eso es
lo primero leer los términos y
condiciones y por otro lado pues ya más
para los niños
restringir ese acceso a las plataformas
digitales y esto pues obviamente viene
desde casa hay que tener en cuenta
los miles de contenidos inapropiados que
hay en las redes sociales
Entonces pues por supuesto nosotros como
padres o madres de familia debemos
controlar eso y sobre el robo de datos
de información pues finalmente somos
nosotros los que estamos dando permisos
y pues en las cláusulas de tiktok
seguramente también hay unos términos y
condiciones que le permiten a esta red
social
negociar con nuestros datos Y pues
obviamente no está bien que el que se
haga y menos en temas gubernamentales
porque por supuesto tenemos derecho a la
información y a la información
transparente pero ese es el riesgo al
que nos exponemos cuando estamos en este
tipo de plataformas pues muchas gracias
Angélica casallas periodista colombiana
especializada en tecnología por sus
apreciaciones sobre el tema
gracias Ángela por invitarme a nuestros
televidentes sigan en directo América ya
volvemos con más